Dragonstone this is yeah Dragonstone
there's been a [ __ ]
[Applause]
biggest is it's it's really a unique
castle I mean it's a you know some of
this is very easy for me as a as a
writer to describe yeah but it's it's
not necessarily easy for the artist to
draw this is probably I think the most
over-the-top illustration and left in
the book but probably the most accurate
to really what's actually described in
the in the book and all the versions of
Dragonstone I mean Dragonstone is is
made by the Valerians who who had
dragons and Dragon Fire and and magical
means of making stone flow and twist and
they could make it into any form that
they wanted to and then it would harden
in that form so they built these massive
structures of not a bricks or stones
mortar together but a solid stone shaped
by intense fires and and and magic and
in the case of Dragonstone like the
towers look like great stone dragons and
you know the entrances look like the
heads of dragons and you know i allude
to this in the book but it's difficult
for an orders to capture so a lot of the
versions that we've had a dragon stone
over the years have been not not really
great and this is one of the best here
by philip strong